Esta es una implementación en JavaScript del
algoritmo de generación de números de Fibonacci
utilizando un enfoque de abajo hacia arriba.
Vamos a avanzar a través de la función para
n igual a 5 y veremos lo que
hace la función paso a paso.
De modo que después de definir la función este
código invoca a fib con 5, entonces estamos en
la función con n igual a 5 y n no es igual
a 0, y tampoco es igual a 1, entonces esta
condición es falsa y bajamos aquí.
Ahora aquí está el verdadero
código de abajo hacia arriba.
Comenzamos declarando tres variables
que serán las únicas variables que necesitamos
aquí y van a recordar tres cosas a la vez.
Así que tenemos dos atrás que inicializamos
en cero, que es el primer número de Fibonacci,
uno atrás que inicializamos en uno, es el segundo
número, y resultado, que inicializamos en cero,
y esta variable al final almacenará
la respuesta que estamos buscando.
Escribimos atrás sin acento porque los
nombres de variables no pueden llevar acentos.
Luego tenemos un bucle for que comienza
en 1 y va por n menos 1 veces. Dentro de
ese bucle for lo primero que hacemos
es definir el valor del resultado,
que es igual a 2 atrás más 1 atrás, así que
esto será igual a 0 más 1. El resultado es
actualmente igual a 1. Entonces hacemos 2 atrás
igual a 1 atrás, para que se convierta en 1,
y hacemos 1 atrás igual a resultado,
para que también se convierta en 1.
Ahora estamos en la siguiente iteración y esta
vez hacemos resultado igual a 2 atrás más 1 atrás,
que será igual a 2, y luego hacemos 2 atrás
igual a 1 atrás que es igual a 1, y hacemos 1
atrás igual al resultado, que es igual a 2.
Ahora estamos en la siguiente iteración.
Hacemos resultado igual a 2 atrás más
1 atrás eso nos dará 3, hacemos 2 atrás
igual a 1 atrás que es igual a 2, y hacemos
1 atrás igual a resultado que es igual a 3.
Siguiente iteración, hacemos resultado igual a
2 atrás más uno atrás, eso nos dará 5. Hacemos
2 atrás igual a 1 atrás que es igual a 3, y
hacemos 1 atrás igual a resultado que es 5.
Ahora, siguiente iteración, ¿la vamos a
hacer? No, en su lugar vamos al final y
devolvemos el valor de resultado, que ahora es
5. Ese es el resultado cuando n es igual a 5,
y este es un enfoque de abajo hacia
arriba para generar números de Fibonacci.